I am excited on a much smaller scale of
uh Mars Europa Titan or Venus
potentially having very like bacteria
like life forms just on a
on a small human level
it's a little bit scary but mostly
really exciting that there might be life
elsewhere in the volcanoes in the oceans
all around us teeming having a lot of
societies and whether there's properties
about that kind of life
that's somehow different than ours I
don't know what would be more exciting
if
those colonies of single cell type
organisms
what would be more exciting if they're
different or they're the same if they're
the same that means
through the rest of the universe there's
life forms like us something like us
everywhere if they're different that's
also really exciting because there's
life forms everywhere they're not like
us
that's a little bit scary I don't know
what's scarier actually I think both
scary and exciting no matter what right
the idea that they could be very
different is philosophically very
interesting for us to open our aperture
on what life and Consciousness and
and self-replicating possibilities could
look like
the question on are they different or
the same obviously there's lots of life
here that is the same in some ways in
different other ways
um when you take the thing that we call
an invasive species is something that's
still pretty the same hydrocarbon based
thing but co-evolved with co-elective
pressures in a certain environment we
move it to another environment it might
be devastating to that whole ecosystem
because it's just different enough that
it messes up the self-stabilizing
Dynamics of that ecosystem so the
question of
are they would they be
different in ways where we could still
figure out a way to inhabit a biosphere
together
or fundamentally not fundamentally the
nature of how they operate and the
nature of how we operate would be
incommensible is a deep question well we
offline talked about mimetic Theory
right it seems like if there were
sufficiently different
or we would not even we can co-exist on
different planes
uh it seems like a a good thing if we're
close enough together to where we'd be
competing then it's you're getting into
the world of viruses and pathogens and
all those kinds of things to where we
would uh
one of us would die off quickly through
basically mass murder
without
even even accidentally even accidentally
if we just had a self-replicating
single-celled kind of creature that
happened to
not work well for the hydrocarbon life
that was here that got introduced
because it either output something that
was toxic or utilized up the same
resource too quickly and it just
replicated faster and mutated faster
that it wouldn't be a
memetic theory conflict theory kind of
harm it would just be uh a Von Neumann
machine a self-replicating machine that
was fundamentally incompatible with
these kinds of self-replicating systems
with faster ooda loops